okay so you know the last couple of
years I was involved in an in a big
project for the Norwegian government to
basically replace their old you know
infrastructure with something
token-based basically openly connect in
Olaf and so on so as part of that
project I created this internal training
to raise awareness of you know security
challenges or you know security features
or security you know problems you might
run into so what this slight lag is it's
basically like a subset of that training
so I picked out like them some more
common problems and maybe some less
common problems to basically raise the
awareness with you as well
and then hopefully encourage you
afterwards to to go start reading these
documents because obviously there is
much much more to learn about this than
what I can tell you in in 60 minutes so
but I have to warn you right when you
start digging into this meta then you're
gonna gonna have to read things like
this right it's a career font right you
know that's where the fun stops here so
very serious lucky lady have a PDF
version for you right so when you when
you click that you really hope give me
something something nicer
apparently the internet doesn't work so
I can I can't show you the PDF version
apparently but the news is the spoiler
alert would be a use the same font okay
so doesn't really help yeah and you know
and that all goes back basically you
know that whole procedure of RFC must be
written in text files and so on that all
goes back basically you know the IETF
work was is the company that specify the
Internet in the first place so basically
all of these documents must really be
backwards compatible to the very first
browser you have ahead did you know the
very first browser you ever had
it's called links right it's a
text-based browser you can see it also
doesn't work
because there is no internet but if you
would open the document in that project
would look exactly the same as in Chrome
so that 30 years of backwards
compatibility and they even had dark
mode back in the day so I think you know
that's pretty good
luckily for the rest of the talk I don't
need internet ok so my name is Dominic
and you know I'm I'm a security
consultant and I also work on this thing
called identity server which is an
open-source implementation of oak MIDI
connector no off so I get to implement
these protocols because you know that
all started as a hobby project really
because I thought you know you can only
really claim you know how the protocols
work when you implement them yourself
and that's what I did so
oh yeah and maybe together important
thing is if you if you want to have two
slides I downloaded them to this thing
called speaker tech comm slash lease
privilege and then you can get the
slides from there
and many other slides okay so then that
the rough agenda is I want to give you a
little bit of an overview where to go to
if you're looking for security guidance
thought for these protocols then I want
to as I said pick out some some concrete
issues and solutions and then in the end
we're going to talk about what's going
to happen with OAuth in the future so
but first give you some context
basically web based authentication
protocols the way we know them today all
had their start in 2005 and the very
first protocol that really you know
invented this pattern of you know you
have a browser you send the user
somewhere that something sends you
something back and that's your
authentication or the token exchange
what's called sam'l to P right it's an
old protocol as you can say it's like 15
years old
but it was only an authentication
protocol because it didn't solve
anything like access to API is or
delegating identity to api's do you know
what because API is didn't exist by the
time then the the first protocol that
actually took on this problem was called
OAuth 1.0 again that's a long time ago
it made some assumptions that are
probably not true anymore today
it involved some pretty you know heavy
crypto it was very complicated to use
for you know many people so the IETF
started
this thing called a Worf 2.0 in 2012
which was a simplification of the old
over of 1.0 protocol and part of that
simplification was basically less crypto
simplified flows - but to be honest also
less security if you look at the
security properties between 1.0 and 2.0
basically because they invented this
thing called para tokens you know where
basically you know if you have two token
you can talk to an API without
cryptographic binding to the client that
requested the token in the first place
so to be honest and maybe some of you
have followed the trauma around that
that the spec offer of o of 2.0 he was
so upset with the IETF you know taking
features and features and features a way
to make it more easy to use that half a
half a year before the spec was done he
just left and made this really popular
talk on the Internet you can search for
it by putting the word or wharf and some
of your favorite swear words in one
sentence and you're going to find it but
part of that legacy from him is that he
demanded that there must be a threat
model right because there are you can
even if you implement a spec word by
words you can implement it in an
insecure way so there must be an
additional document on top that
basically looks at all of the security
properties looks at the all of the
attack scenarios that you know that you
could think of and you know tell people
how to fix them but obviously since this
document was written at the same time as
the protocol itself there was no no
experience yet how will people use the
protocol however people attacked a
protocol right so the threat model is if
you think the OAuth spec is boring that
fret model is not much more exciting to
be honest yeah because it you know as I
said they didn't really know how that
thing will be broken in the future so
there was that there's no actionable
guidance here really it's just basically
this could go wrong and this could go
wrong it just could go wrong and you
have to fix it somehow okay so then you
know many other protocols came down the
line actually someone recently just
counted the pages of all of the
documents of all of the specs and
realized it's double the size double the
number of pages than Warren piece okay
so which you then decide which one is
more exciting to read and now we saw oh
of being used in in places where we
probably or where in 2012 nobody
anticipated it going like financial
industry healthcare sector you know
high-value scenarios and guess what as
more high-value the scenarios get a more
creative attacker scared to find the
problems right so there was like a
demand of giving us something better
than just a raw threat model so if they
started coming up with what they called
PC peace and PC P stands for best
current practice okay and it's good that
the word current is in there because
obviously as older as the document gets
the current is you know it's less
current right I'm still they're all you
know pretty new ish and the idea of that
PCP was to give you as a developer real
actionable guidance like if you're doing
this then you wanted to implement
exactly like this because that's the
recommendation okay so that's the very
first PCP that came out was the one for
native apps that's been released in 2017
and very soon there will be a couple of
new PC piece one is called Leo of two
security topics which is more like a
general thing that update applies to all
applications and the one that many many
people have been waiting for is called
OAuth 2 for browser-based application
for example because as we know that's
the most problematic type of client to
secure and basically what this talk is
about is to give you an overview of
these PCPs how they hang together and as
I said hopefully encourage you to read
them because as I said yes more more to
learn so yeah so basically we have to
fret model like the mother of all BCPs
if you like we have 200 of two security
best current practice and on top we have
two very specific ones if you're writing
native apps or browser-based
applications and the one thing they
sneaked in recently is two more what is
about using chasing depth tokens with
OAuth because you know in the beginning
ooofff did not specify a concrete token
format they just said use a token right
but it's very common these days to use
JSON web tokens for this so that's
talking about this and they do these two
specs kind of go hand-in-hand together
okay
so how does an OAuth open ID connect
based system look like something like
this right we have front end we have
back ends we have backends for backends
wherever an arrow goes to there needs to
be some authentication right so it turns
out omadi Connect is the less critical
problem here because it's not giving you
access to something it's only about
representing identity but whenever an
arrow arrives at a Web API right that is
basically where potentially the right
well there are access tokens used if
they get stolen or you know somehow
misused then you can access resources
maybe you know not legitimately
so but if you strip down this picture it
really always looks like this right
everyo off based system looks like this
you have a client which is the
application you have a resource owner
which I typically call the user you have
a resource server which is typically an
API and you have to sync all the
authorization server which is the thing
that issues your tokens issues tokens to
the client I should be very specific to
access the resource ok so if you think
about a security of such a system it's
the first thing you should probably
think about this who is gonna attack it
or what kind of a checker can we expect
and you know what excuse me I've found
the cheesiest symbol for an attacker on
the internet so I think that's how they
look like I've never met one but I think
that's how they look like so the very
temp the very first type of attack you
should think about is basically if your
infrastructure is compromised right
maybe you're not using TLS which would
be a very big failure or maybe you have
TLS and it's compromised somehow reverse
proxy is you know root certificates
whatever or maybe even worth your DNS
infrastructure is compromised and to be
honest with you that pretty much game
over right that is something as
developers that we can't fix that that
has to be done at the infrastructure
level the next one that we probably
can't fix as you know developers is if
the endpoints
being compromised I mean you have to ask
yourself okay why are they being
compromised somebody wrote bad code that
with this attack model the reason they
are compromised it's not because of the
protocols that's the idea right somebody
found some other vulnerability on the
server or something they could
compromise the API they could compromise
the token service or maybe declined now
again that's not really what we want to
talk about today
a very interesting attack model which is
in my opinion like the battleground of
the future is basically if attackers can
register additional infrastructure yes
maybe they can bring up rogue clients or
rogue api's or rogue authorization
servers into the system and even worse
maybe take they can register the rogue
client with the legitimate authorization
server or have the legitimate client
talk to the rogue authorization server
you know these kinds of combinations
where you know still the protocol might
be completely spec compliant but you are
now hitting a scenario that you haven't
thought about and this might confuse you
yeah and that is what we see these days
with very targeted attacks yeah when
somebody is specifically targets a
certain company that is you know that's
where many things go on but sadly enough
like the 80% of all the vulnerabilities
are just implementation mistakes right
basically the idea is that an attacker
can read but not modify the content of
the authorization request or response
and that might be because we have open
redirect us in our code yeah we have we
are leaking data yeah maybe in log files
maybe in the browser history maybe in in
proxies maybe you have something on the
phone that intercepts the call backs
between applications and so on that is
by far the most common problem we see
and the good news is they are all just
programming errors and we can fix them
okay good so this these pcps have been
around for a while and no one really
took too much attention and unless one
very respected colleague of mine tossed
and polished it wrote a blog post he
said like you should stop using the or
of implicit grant and he made it very
clear by scary
people say like if you don't your health
records might be leaked or someone is
initiating payment from your bank
account yeah and you can only imagine
what happened next day right I got
emails and phone calls from companies
and customers saying hey have you read
this blog post there's a new
vulnerability in OAuth and you last week
you recommended us using the OAuth
implicit flow are you aware of that and
I had to do a lot of explaining saying
this is not a new vulnerability right
from the start
if you would have read the threat model
of OAuth it says the implicit flow is a
simplified model made for simplified
clients which were called by the time
JavaScript runs right and it's
error-prone you can protect against the
weaknesses of the implicit flow but you
have to write code for that and you have
to understand those weaknesses yeah so
long story short this blog post started
the whole thing and now the idea is that
the implicit flow will be deprecated
okay just to recap very quickly what's
the implicit flow it's basically as I
said a simplified version of OAuth that
was built for browsers that did not
support cross-origin Ajax calls right
because in 2012 we didn't of course by
the time so we couldn't do cross-origin
Ajax calls so they send around the
tokens on the URL okay that was the only
thing that was working as you can
imagine that this is error-prone
this can leak data if you don't protect
against it but now in 2020 we do have
cross-origin Ajax calls and there's no
need anymore to use this simplified
version of it so don't use it anymore
okay don't use it while we are you know
and you know that's the summary of the
reasons I just told you it's error-prone
while we are at deprecating flows the
next flow that has been deprecated is
the so called password trend you know
the password trend is this approach
where you collect the clutter that the
users credentials in the front end then
send the credit to the server and then
you get a token back or the the real
name is the resource owner password
grant now as they call it this one is
also outdated for a couple of reasons
right I mean the more you educate your
users to type in passwords in different
places
research shows the more they are prone
for you know falling for phishing
attacks for example because they just
have to type in the password so often
then we don't think about it anymore
right but if you only have this one
place that you asked for passwords and
that it's not happening that frequently
then maybe you think about why do I have
to type in my password here maybe that's
not a legitimate place to do that yeah
also you know that flow is not
compatible with any of the modern
authentication techniques like Fido and
two-factor authentication and Federation
and so on so yeah
stop stop using that the nice thing
about deprecating flows that you know
where may be useful eight years ago but
are not that useful anymore today is is
to it
drastically simplifies an OAuth based
system right so one year ago if you
would have asked me which flow do I have
to use for an application type that
would kind of be like your decision
matrix right but now with deprecation of
all of these flows actually it becomes
very easy okay so the consensus is that
we really only need two flows because we
really only write two types of
applications one is a non-interactive
application which is just machine to
machine communication we have a flow for
that called the client credential flow
and the other one is an interactive
application basically meaning a user is
involved sits in front of a computer for
all of these types of scenarios we have
this thing called the authorization code
flow which has been around for a very
long time guess what your authorization
code flow on its own is vulnerable to
something which I'll show you in a
second that's why there is a thing on
top called pixie as the cool kids call
it which stands for proof key for code
exchange and I'm gonna show you in a
second term how that works okay so let's
start with the machine-to-machine
scenario because that's the simpler one
to you know to understand it's very
simple you have a client you have the
token service you have an API the client
authenticates with the token service you
know by using client ID and seek
it asks for access to a resource which
is typically an API and if that is all
the cheat he gets back an access token
and then uses that access token to call
the API right that's as easy as it is
the first thing I want to put your
attention to is client secrets right so
again you know of client secret is an
abstraction yeah it says the client uses
some sort of secret now to authenticate
with the server and obviously the most
simplest secret that at least many
people think is what they call a shared
secret right so basically the client has
has a value the server has a value the
client sends it over the wire right and
if they match the client is reclaims to
be obviously a shared secret is not
really a secret right because you shared
it yeah but that's another story I guess
but shared secrets only look easier on
the outside once you build a real system
of shared secrets right configuration
management is hard you have to think
about key rotation because maybe you
don't want to keep the same secret for
all the time how do you store them how
do you deal with them at development
time how you make sure they don't end up
in your github account right all these
things make make shared secrets harder
to use if you have to use them make sure
they have a high entropy like goo it for
example you know random strings I mean
these are in essence they are passwords
for machines right machines don't need
easy to remember passwords they can use
hard to remember passwords never ever
store them in clear text on your server
you always use non-reversible encryption
or also called hashing em so that if
somebody actually compromises your
server database they don't get like a
list of all of your client secrets that
should not happen ma'am since they are
high entropy you don't have to provide
things like stretching algorithms right
you only do that for passwords for
humans because they are typically bad if
you have the luxury of moving away from
that go to asymmetric keys right public
private key pairs where the client has
the private key the server has the
public here the server does not need to
store any secret at all because public
keys are not secret the client creates
some data typically a JSON web token
signs that token with the private key
sends that json web token over the wire
no secret goes over the wire right only
the signed artifact so to speak so that
that's much better yeah again if you if
someone has access to your network for
example it they won't see those secrets
yeah and the most common ways of doing
that today is the signed shots you know
chasing laptop as I just said or using
mutual TLS yes a mutual TLS has kind of
like a renascence the last years it was
really hard to deploy you know when
people think oh yeah CAS and PKI and so
on this has all gotten much much easier
these days so you know maybe you want to
reconsider mutual TLS the nice thing
about mutual TLS is it provides us with
a mechanism to buy into the token to the
client right so I said in the beginning
there are tokens are a simplified
version of a token where whoever has the
token like it's it's like money you find
on the street right if I find some money
I can use it that's a pair of token
there is a credit card it's more like
pound to the owner but if a picture or a
signature or a pin maybe right same same
analogy if you're using neutral TLS
that's really powerful because when the
client asks for a token using the mutual
TLS connection the server can read the
thumbprint of the client certificate can
embed the value of that function into
the access token and when then the
client opens the connection to the API
he will use the same client certificate
so what the API can do is read the
thumbprint from the TLS connection
compare a value in the token and only if
they match the client has proven that he
was the client that asked for the token
in the first place and even attack I
would be able to steal that token
leaking whatever he would not have that
private key so he couldn't use the token
right so that's the way to go okay
talking about chasing up tokens ma'am
they've become massively massively
popular right so as I said when Olaf was
specified
chasing laptops didn't even exist right
but over the last five years or so
you know they became widely available
Jason is the you know data format of
choice I guess
chasing their token libraries are
available everywhere I'm so people
started using chasing their tokens all
a place right in oak MediConnect we have
identity tokens we have access token to
know off we have lockout tokens we have
security events and then people come up
with all kinds of you know you know
basically di-did the nice thing about
chasing web tokens is it's a way to
protect a JSON object so if you want to
express anything as a JSON object but
need like integrity protection and
authenticity chasing their tokens are
the way to go that's a very typical
chase in-depth rogen right it's a header
a payload and so on they are kind of
like they're a victim of their own
popularity kind of yeah
because that's from the oak MediConnect
back yeah they they use a JSON web token
to send as a logout token so these are
the validation steps you have to do yeah
so let's have a look validate the
signature okay make sense validate the
token contains a sub claim it's a big
claim okay make sense verify that the
token does not contain a nonce claim so
that's that's weird right so the reason
why they have that in there is because
if that token would contain a nonce
claim it would be indistinguishable from
an identity token so somebody could send
an identity token to the lockout
endpoint and they will lock out even if
he doesn't have a lookout token right so
and the problem with that is that they
all look pretty much the same all right
so if you start if you're using M JSON
web tokens then you should start using
what they call typed JSON web tokens
yeah so you see the type the the type
claim or value you see at the top
normally this just says JWT right but
the new spec says if if this token is a
is an access token call it 80 plus JWT
and that is roughly around the same idea
as content types or you know hypermedia
types in the web so whenever you come up
with a token or a thing that you want to
represent as a JSON web token come up
with a type so that the recipient can
actually check that value make sure hate
is this really what I'm expecting and
not something that is also adjacent
their token and look just very similar
to what I'm expecting okay so starting
with the latest version of identity
server for example all of our access
tokens look like this they have 280 plus
JWT on top and I would encourage your
doing the same
if you have your own tokens okay let's
switch our attention to interactive
applications which are much easier to
attack because they are more complicated
so if the application is interactive
there will be always like a two's
two-part process right one is the the
interactive part that helped it's
happening in the browser where you know
a user can see some sort of UI and then
the non interactive part where on the
back-channel you're getting the tokens
now proud of a crate right because they
can show UI and they follow redirects
right but processes are very problematic
why well because they show UI and they
follow redirects yeah sometimes to the
wrong place yeah and that's exactly the
problem here but you know I'll you know
in a nutshell the way this works is if
you open the front channel connection
wire the browser that actually
authorized request that goes to the
token server the talks ever shows the UI
and everything that's needed then when
that is done the token service returns
the so called authorization code back to
the client application then the client
application opens the back-channel
communication to turn that code into
tokens okay so that the client sends the
code the secret and so on and then
ultimately gets back his access token so
yeah that's you know the way this flow
works now the spec says you know you can
imagine that this this callback here
coming from the server back here is
pretty much sensitive right because that
that delivers the artifact back to your
client application and the spec says
very very clearly you have to whitelist
these what I call redirect you arise and
when the client asks for that or sends
you that URI you have to do and accepts
a string matching between what you have
registered in your database and what the
client wants and if they don't match
don't accept it okay that's what the
spec says very clear yeah guess what
people do you know is that really
necessary can't be make it more you know
like more flexible for example and these
are two things I saw in real life yeah
for example have to the redirect URI
being star
at my app calm so we can use any sub
domain in indebt DNS namespace right why
would that be problematic well generally
speaking right the more flexibility you
allow the bigger your attack surface
gets where tokens or codes can be
delivered to where you have an
implementation flaw if you only have
this one endpoint that has only one
purpose in life is handling the callback
then you can you know check that code
much better than having any endpoint on
any subdomain okay that actually
happened last year to you know a EA
Electronic Arts so what they did was you
know some EA developer went to Asha
created a website that that was called 1
2 3 and Asha websites dotnet right then
this was done it was the new peelings
site stir then at EA someone made a DNS
entry to point billing dot EA dot-com to
one to free as a website's dotnet right
that's what they call custom domains or
custom host names are saying yeah all is
good
now after a year they decided to remove
the peeling website and move it
somewhere else so they shut down the
Asha website but no one removed the DNS
entry so now there was a DNS entry
hanging there that points to a
non-existent website you can query a DNS
server and all they had to do was
register one to free it Asia web sites
dotnet which which was still free by the
time and then you can run code under the
EA domain right
that's called subdomain takeover you
know it sounds funny but it's it's
pretty effective yes so don't do that
ma'am yet the other thing I've seen in
real life is it's some site or comm
slash star ok we fix the DNS name but
any page on that server will do that
exactly happened to actually get up and
Facebook and some other big companies so
basically some some pretty smart guy
found that out
he basically sent out emails pointing to
a URL on that site let's imagine it's
facebook.com slash my Facebook page ok
so he send out his emails people were
clicking it they came to Facebook they
probably were locked in already so they
didn't see their login page
it just sent the code directly to that
callback you
it was this attackers page and guess
what he did on that page he posted a
picture that came from a server that he
controls okay so now the browser arrives
at the page he loads the images he goes
out to evil calm
what is the browser sending a referral
header right
and on that referer header is the
original URL which has the code and now
all the guy had to do is look at his log
files of his depth server and he got all
of the codes that were produced as part
of the authentication process that's
pretty cool right yeah you have to give
him respect for that I think now you say
why is this dangerous why didn't you
just say I need to have a client secret
to be able to turn that code back into a
token yeah do you there's another attack
which is called authorization code
injection so the idea is yes you are
right that the attacker himself cannot
turn a code into a token because he's
missing the client secret but what if he
now has harvested those those codes okay
and now he goes to the legitimate
website starts the authentication
process right and on the way back he
injects the stolen code what will the
client do well he will happily take that
stolen code use his client ID and secret
and turn it into tokens right and now
I'm locked in as the victim makes sense
yeah that's also pretty clever
this attack was became published after
the initial a Wharf spec so the
authorization code flow has no
protection against this yeah so they
have added an additional thing as I said
called proof key for code exchange or
pixie and basically it's a simple
extension to the code flow which which
solves the problem so the idea is the
client before he starts the
authorization request he creates a
random number that's a secret that only
the client knows he writes a random
number and then he hashes that random
number so that the random number is
called the code verifier the hashed
version is called the code challenge so
now he's sending the hashed version of
that number to the authorized request
okay so the code comes back right and
then on the back channel he's sending
the clear text version of the random
number so now the server has both the
hashed version and the clear text
version so he hashes the clear text
version if the hashes match the prod
that the client has proven that he's the
same client on the front channel as he
is on the back channel okay
so now if I would now come with my
stolen code that stolen code would have
a different code challenge associated
with it than the one I'm gonna generate
they will not match for the server will
reject the request okay so you have to
use that if using authorization code
flow because that's the only way to fix
the problem well that's the most common
way to fix the problem let's put it this
way
okay so let's pick C so as a summary now
always do exact matching of URLs never
allow any flexibility don't think you
are clever because you can use regular
expressions okay we all know we all
failed with that at some point in our
career right where we thought I can
master them
beware of open who directors don't build
build pages that somehow forward traffic
to another thing based on input right
that's called an open director that
might leak your data always use pick C
always use content security policy
[Music]
immediately invalidate authorization
codes after they've been used make them
one-time-only tokens and you know what a
very simple and effective thing is use
refer a policy is to make sure that your
browser doesn't send referral headers
right that's just a simple fix that
could have saved Facebook of course okay
now let's look at something which is
much more advanced than I just showed
you okay that is actually that blew my
mind the very first time I saw it and I
had to read it like five times to
understand it it's called a mix up
attack yeah and the idea of that mix of
attack is is that your client
application trusts more than one
external provider okay that might be the
client itself it might be your
Federation gauge where you're running
okay so let's say you allow registration
of providers maybe you're running a
software as a service product and the
customer can
self-register their own authentication
system because they want to get single
sign-on right so now you have multiple
things here and maybe one of them is not
so trusted as the other yeah so they
call it the attacker authorization
server and honest authorization server
okay so this very first very end of the
mix-up attack is you know has some has
some assumptions but it basically works
like this you know the user clicks a
link he wants to log in with the honest
STS now the attacker somehow has access
to the network and he can on the fly
change that to login with the attack
IIST yes okay so now the client will say
ok he clicked the attacker SDS link and
then we'll send him back a redirect back
to the attacker STS on the way back the
attacker switches back that thing to do
a redirect to the honest test yes okay
so is it already hurting yeah I hope so
here now the the browser will may do a
redirect to the honest STS will
authenticate he will get back a code the
code will travel back to the client
where does the client now think he has
to send his client ID in secret to to
the attacker STS okay
and now the attack is TS can just use
the code in the secret and so on to get
a token no now you might say huh
that means he has network access right
and if he has network access maybe ten
this is not my biggest problem and yeah
I agree if partially the next variant of
that requires no network access okay
it's a little bit different so in this
case imagine the attacker has registered
in STS which looks like something that
somebody wants to use yeah so they click
the wrong button in the UI for the
attack is TS right so the redirect goes
to the attacker STS
okay that looks good now the attacker
STS turns around changes his client ID
and and redirect URI in everything and
forwards the call to the honest test yes
so now the user sees the real login page
of the real thing he fought he's talking
to so now the honest STS comes back to
client and where does the client send a
client that he in secret to the attacker
yes okay so yes that is nothing made up
that really happened okay
the good news is yeah if you are using a
good framework okay you are properly
secure already but let you know I've
reviewed so many hand-rolled or of
implementations in my life that
definitely were not secured against this
attack but basically that the fix is
pretty simple
das needs to always remember where he's
going to he needs to have a s specific
callback URLs but that only can process
the this specific a s and then make sure
they match okay so if you're using HP
nerdcore for example they have a
built-in countermeasure and to be honest
this was built even before the attack
was known so maybe it's a bit like
secure by accident maybe not maybe
someone was really forth looking that's
even in in katana already yeah so it's
it's it's actually around for a long
time the way this works in a spinnaker
is that each external provider must have
a unique name and a unique callback URL
okay so when they now do the authorized
request out to the provider they
basically create the challenge then they
create a correlation ID which is a
random number and then they encrypt and
sign that correlation ID on the state
parameter so it basically round trips
back and forth and then they create an
cookie which is called correlation
thought authorizations of a name dot
correlation idea okay so now the
callback comes back from that external
system so basically it's on the AAS one
specific callback it still has the
correlation ID on the state so they
unprotect that string right they get the
correlation ID and then they make sure
there is a cookie that has exactly dis
name and if this cookie doesn't exist
you know that the initiation of the
request and the response where four
different authorization servers okay and
then they're going to throw an exception
something like correlation failed you
probably all have seen that error in the
ethnic or correlation failed
and that's what you get so yeah that's
how what you would need to do if you're
building your own little framework and
as I said it's built into a spinet core
okay let's switch gears a little bit to
public lines you know public lines are
clients in a wharf speak which are not
on a server which can't store a secret
they don't have a secret right they are
deployed to a phone or to a browser side
its Chavez script basically yeah in
other words you can't authenticate the
client you can't rely on the client
secret protection for your authorization
code and so on so forth yeah and that
would be typically as I said native apps
are browser-based apps so the first
anti-pattern is this right native login
dialogues I know some native developers
have this urge to create a native log in
dialogues don't do it if you don't trust
my advice then tell everyone this is
using a deprecated flow it's you think
the password flow right which are just
deprecated 20 minutes ago so don't use
it for the reasons I mentioned earlier
okay obviously did the recommended flow
for native apps is because you're not in
the browser you open a browser right
it's that easy
so that browser goes to your normal
login page with your you know all of
your code you're logging and auditing
and your Federation and two-factor and
whatever you have which is you know it's
basically you're making you're making
sure your authentication related code is
in one place and not in five apps spread
around yeah when you can make it even
better by using the so called system
browser right so many UI frameworks have
the concept of a vet view which is
basically a browser inside your
application without the chrome around
yeah don't do that yeah it's bad it's a
people can't see where they are people
cannot inspect the certificate if they
really want to maybe perfect managers
won't work but the real reason why you
want to use the system browser is
because this browser shares the cookie
container with all of your other
authentication stage right so if you're
already logged in to let's say Google
then you get single sign-on with Google
inside the native app without having to
type in the password again because the
cookies are still there right and as we
know the less often you have to type a
password there
the better from a security point of view
okay so yes that's the recommended flow
for native apps using exactly the same
flow I've just shown you which is
causation code flow with pixie now you
might ask yourself are no client secret
that the code is even more vulnerable
here and again that's what pixie saves
us from right because even if the client
does not have a static secret which is
no secret anyways right it has a per
request secret write the code challenge
and the code verify they create a per
request secret and if somebody can
intercept that code he doesn't know the
random number he still cannot turn that
code back into tokens and that's exactly
what we want okay as I said there are a
couple of approaches here we have the
system browser we have private browsers
and so on as if you can always use the
system browser then there are a couple
of ways how you handle the callback
you know with custom uri schemes may be
my preferred one is what we called
claimed HTTP https you arise it's
basically you know you've seen that
before maybe when you open a link to
let's say Amazon and you have installed
the Amazon app on the phone instead
instead of opening the browser it opens
the app and that's why and that's
because on that link there is an XML
file that is signed with your Apple
Developer certificate which says hey
when you get a link to that open the
Amazon app instead if it is installed on
the machine and that's how you can
nicely do the callback from the browser
back to your application okay yeah this
is a set as part of the talk I'm sorry
browser-based applications okay
everybody does sparse right they had a
hotness I guess and unfortunately there
what have most hard hardest to secure
type of application and you know the
problem is not the spa or the or or the
protocol or whatever the problem is the
browser right you're ultimately you're
running your application in a shared
execution environment with you know
multiple applications that take
advantage of the shared state that the
browser provides and there's a whole
class of attacks that you know have the
word cross in front right for cross
scripting cross-site request forgery
because basically one application
attacks the other trying to take
advantage of the shared state in the
browser right so you know fundamentally
there are two different ways to secure
Espace either one is using a credential
type that the browser natively
understands like a cookie for example or
you're using something explicit which
could be an OAuth access token right it
turns out the cookie has the cross-site
request forgery problem and the access
token has to cross-site scripting
problem so you choose which problem you
prefer ma'am funnily enough yeah the so
yeah so basically we were asking for
this PCP for a long time like can we
have an O or for web applications PCP
just like we have for the native one and
the ITF was tracking their feet for a
long time because they knew they kind of
opened Pandora's box here right because
it in the end it will come out it's not
oh of it's the browser yeah
so funnily enough the or for
browser-based apps
PCP is the first or spec I ever read
that says and maybe you don't need to
use OAuth oh yeah and their assumption
is this most applications out there yeah
they kind of look like this right you
have a domain you have a browser front
end you have a back-end API and they
might run on the same site okay so you
can secure the communication between the
two with cookies okay you still might
use an external identity system that's
totally fine yeah you still might have
to call some external API but 90% of the
communication is same site right so you
can actually use the cookie and apply
some sort of anti fitori protection to
it yeah
now the PCP makes the assumption that
this anti-fur tree protection will be a
same site cookies right that's this new
newish feature in in browsers it's
called same side cookies that basically
makes sure that you know when you get a
cookie from domain one that the browser
will only send that cookie back to
domain one if the sender's come
from the same site okay a site is by the
way not an origin right and origin is
very strict with protocol DNS name and
port let us say the site basically means
it's the top-level DNS registrar name so
API dot my apt or command app what my
apt of comm would be on the same side so
that would work okay MVC has only four
three protection built-in for many many
many years actually since day day one I
think yeah but you have to write code
for that with the same side cookie it's
more like a processing and you probably
also know that the internet will get
more secure next week or broken as some
people call it when Google decides to
change the default value for same side
cookies right so up to up to today you
have to opt into same side protection
starting next week chrome will basically
treat every cookie that does not opt-out
automatically as the same side cookie
which means it will not travel across
site borders anymore and if you haven't
tested your web app you should do it
very soon it's gonna be for for February
okay so ultimately ultimately the PCP
distinguishes between these two
scenarios here one they call JavaScript
apps with with a back-end and one is
called JavaScript apps without a
back-end yeah and I am to be honest I'm
not really happy about about this
classification I think it should be
rather a question like do you want to
store your tokens on the server or do
you want to store your tokens on the
client right if you are running you know
on the server you might have a better
feeling because they are away from the
browser away from your cross-site
scripting attacks but you're pretty much
limited by what cookies can do and if
you're starting to do a lot of
cross-site API calls the cookie won't
help you yeah but if you're storing them
in the browser you now have you know you
have to be very careful with cross-site
scripting but it's it's more flexible
right so there are different threat
models I guess and there's no
one-size-fits-all answer here I'm a
consultant I would say it depends right
but yeah but the real question you have
to ask yourself is you know am i
protected enough against cross-site
scripting or not if
don't have to feelin you you know you
can deal with that maybe storing all of
your tokens in the browser you know can
be problematic that doesn't mean you are
safe from cross-site scripting with both
approaches here I'm just saying it's a
different threat model right and you
have to you have to think about that
okay now yeah I mentioned that also in
you know think about refresh token
storage in browsers right there is some
guidance here as well and one of the
interesting things that you can bind
your refresh token lifetime to the
session lifetime for example that might
help you but yeah again much more
information in these documents that you
should read now what's next right so
I've now gave you an excerpt of these
documents right and you that kind of
implies there's more yeah so you might
think now huh you know that sounds all
very you know risky and so on and guess
what else just even like there are
academic research papers that found even
more problems yeah so do the IETF is
working on that right it turns out to
cut a long story short the most
vulnerable part of Oh Wharf is still the
browser right I'm you know I mentioned
that they follow redirects they show you
I right that's what makes them powerful
and dangerous and it turns out in the
grand scheme the problem the biggest
problem are the authorized request right
the initial requests why out of browser
front channel to the authorization
server so there are a couple of new
specs up to even just work the work has
started on this okay part the IETF is
not like the fastest moving company on
the planet as you probably know so this
will take many many years right but in
the meantime what I think is a real
possibility is that we're gonna have
oh of 2.1 first so what is 2.1 it's
pretty much what I what I told you about
yeah like deprecated flows only two code
flow with pixie already duke language
engine slow some of the other things and
one orbit or two additional specs they
are working on right now is and they say
like hey if the authorized request is
the biggest problem can we make that
better
okay and you authorize requests remember
that's the thing where you why other
browser send all of all of these
parameters to the authorization server
and they can be you know tweaked by
someone or handcrafted and can probably
be used to you know to do something that
you didn't intend to do so what about we
turned the other thing into this what's
that it's clearly a chasing web token
right because there are two dots in it
yeah of course yeah
and this chase in depth token basically
is the query string just as a chasing up
token it's signed right look at that it
is a type yes the date they take their
own guidance so yeah that's that's an
interesting idea right depending on how
big these tokens get you might have
problems with URL length descriptions
and so on so there's another spec that
sits on top of that which i think is
just a brilliant idea how about this you
don't do the authorize request at all as
the first thing you first open a
back-channel communication to your token
server you authenticate the client
however strong you can authenticate the
client and then on that back channel the
client pushes the authorization request
parameters to the server and then the
server stores them and returns that
client back a reference to them okay
that's all happening on the back channel
so now on the front Channel now the
client will use that reference to make
the authorized request okay so no more
front channel harmed during the process
so to speak right all of the stuff is
happening on the back channel that's
what you get on the front channel no one
really well no one today as we know it
can tamper with these things I'm pretty
sure there will be clever people who
find different ways of that but yeah
that's basically where it's heading to
right get rid of the front channel or at
least make it much more secure that spec
is called pushed authorization requests
yeah and respect before it's called
chasing JWT secured authorize requests
now so they kind of go hand in hand did
this one is really really nice you know
we have support for Charles today and
Carson hopefully during dead-dead year
okay so what's the summary here is that
depressing to you things like hey why do
I have to use a wharf at all it seems
very insecure right so many
vulnerabilities and so on and my answer
is yes you should use a wharf because
you know that the beauty of having a
speck and a standard is is that you're
having a pre vetted threat model right
many people wrote work on the standards
many people try to break it yeah if you
think like no I'm gonna write my own
protocol there will be one person who
wrote the protocol and probably only one
person who broke it right that's you and
I think that's better
yeah so you know to summarize that some
things we can't fix which is
infrastructure stuff some things can be
easily fixed right get rid of your
referrals get rid of your open with
directors get rid of your leaking stuff
right some frets will be always hard to
mitigate right if if an attacker wants
to specifically attack your company
they're gonna analyze how your stuff
works and find your weaknesses right
it's more like a an assassination than a
drive-by shooting kind of thing yeah so
yes I think still you should all use
OAuth I think I think we we have some
things challenges I would like to condom
yeah and we can fix them and but it's
getting better every day so thank you
for that don't I always forget we have
stickers if you want to stick out there
outside it is a big sign saying identity
server you can have because they are and
besides that thank you for your time
[Applause]